ganz schlechte nachrichten für alle die
in köln wohnen und aus der kirche
austreten wollen bis ende april sind
alle online termine beim zuständigen
abend leider ausgebucht ist ja keine
frage wenn so viele raus wollen
gleichzeitig hat das viele gründe
aber in dem fall hat ein mann schon sehr
mitgeholfen der immer selig lächelnde
erzbischof rainer maria woelki ja gegen
den gibt es einen regelrechten aufstand
so ist man so sagen fahr gemeinden
katholische verbände sein eigener statt
dich hand was immer das ist verweigern
ihm die zusammenarbeit als noch nie
gegeben warum weil hoch wirken erst mit
großem tamtam einen missbrauchs
gutachten angekündigt hat um es dann
nicht zu veröffentlichen
wegen zitat methodischer mängel viele
woelki sätze klingen jetzt im nachhinein
irgendwie holen
unser kölner jetzt bistum wird sich der
wahrheit stellen auch dann wenn diese
schmerzlich ist und dazu gehört es
ungeschönt und ohne falsche rücksichten
aufzuklären es sei denn was beim
rücksichtslosen auf kleinen rauskommt
gefällt mir nicht
ja das bistum aachen hat übrigens bei
derselben anwaltskanzlei ein gutachten
bestellt und veröffentlicht so geht
transparenz und nicht anders methodische
mängel in der kanzlei in münchen
arbeitet an juristin die früher die cosa
nostra verfolgt hat die kennen sich also
eindeutig aus mit organisierter
kriminalität leider hat das vertuschen
von missbrauch tradition in der kirche
wissen sie geht ja ganz weit zurück im
kölner dom hängt ein tryptichon das
zeigt die geschichte von sankt
pädophilie er wurde am 5
jahrhundert wegen missbrauchs verhaftet
und direkt wieder freigelassen weil die
weltlichen justiz gar nicht zuständig
ist und zur strafe nur nach regensburg
versetzt wo die domspatzen leiten musste
das war ihm eine lehre
rainer maria woelki hatte eine art
mentor ein fahrer der ende der 70er in
kindergarten kind missbraucht haben soll
das hat die kirche auch zugegeben denn
2011 wurden 15.000 euro entschädigung
gezahlt 2012 begleitet aber genau dieser
priester johannes so woelki zu seiner
kardinalserhebung in den vatikan
quasi als ehrengast nach recherchen des
kölner stadt-anzeigers wurde woelki aber
wohl schon im juni 2011 in den fall
eingeweiht
ganz sicher ist er hat ihn nach rom
gemeldet mit der begründung der täter
sei da schon zu alt und zu krank gewesen
alleine dafür hätte wirklich sich längst
entschuldigen müssen hatte auch
weihnachten hat er versucht auf seine
art was ihr an der kritik darüber und
insbesondere auch an der kritik an
meiner person ertragen mussten
für all das bitte ich sie um verzeihung
mir tut das so von herzen leid dass die
blöde lügen presse von all dem wind
gekriegt hat liebe gemeinde
er fühlt sich von den medien verfolgt
man schätzt dass sein bistum für pr
berater und anwälte rund dreimal so viel
ausgegeben hat wie für die entschädigung
der missbrauchsopfer der welt lässt sich
halt juristisch nur von den allerbesten
beraten unter anderem dabei ist die
kanzlei höcker die auch den türkischen
präsidenten erdogan und die afg vertrat
cool woelki erdogan und die afg treffen
sich beim anwalt klingt wie der anfang
von dem ganz schlimm wird's journalisten
die das geheime gutachten sehen wollten
mussten vorher in köln eine
vertraulichkeitsvereinbarung
unterschreiben also nichts darüber
berichten natürlich keiner gemacht wir
medien sind das problem
oder in den worten des kölner
weihbischofs ans kap of joseph goebbels
wird der satz zugeschrieben man muss
eine lüge nur oft genug wiederholen dann
wird sie auch geglaubt wiederholungen
allein machen eine aussage nicht
automatisch war auch nicht wenn es um
das
angebliche fehlverhalten von bischöfen
geht manche sachen muss man aber ständig
wiederholen weil manche angeblichen
christen sie nicht hören wollen
der herr prof ich sage einfach gerne den
namen bin ein schlichtes gemüt ist
kardinal woelki noch zu halten diese
woche hat er der kölnischen rundschau
gesagt zitat ich habe mein gewissen
geprüft und bin persönlich der
überzeugung dass ich mich korrekt
verhalten habe aha vielleicht einfach
noch mal von vorne prüfen
rösler nein es gibt ja präzedenzfälle
hier erzbischof anno im jahr 1074 von
wütenden kölnern aus dem dom vertrieben
da konnte im letzten moment durch ein
loch in der stadtmauer fliehen
der volksmund sprach vom sogenannten
analog kölner humor apropos analog die
katholische kirche muss sich endlich der
wurzel ihres problemstellen der
komischen sexualmoral
ja und das betrifft übrigens auch hier
den großen reformer franziskus ein
journalist fragt den papst wie eltern
sich verhalten sollen wenn ihr kind
homosexuelle neigungen zeige beten
antwortet franziskus zunächst nicht
verdammen
wenn es sich in der kindheit zeigt kann
man noch einiges machen mit psychiatrie
oder sehen wie die dinge sind
homosexuelle kinder in die psychiatrie
mal was anderes der ansatz am besten
wäre die halten sich ganz raus aus
sämtlichen untenrum themen machen sie
aber nicht neu allerdings gibt es ja
sogar einen tatsächlich war katholischen
porno kanal katholen youporn heißt dass
dieses video heißt in der gemeindearbeit
aktives ehepaar hat freudlosen sex im
dunkeln weil es noch ein kind will oder
hier von fleischeslust gequälter
gottesmann denkt darüber nach hand an
sich zu legen lässt es dann aber doch
noch verschwand das hier der katholische
dreier ein mann mit zwei frauen
gleichzeitig beim frühstück und einer
davon ist eine schwiegermutter für mich
zu hardcore junge der vatikan sieht
absurderweise bis heute keinen
zusammenhang zwischen zölibat und
missbrauch
was die da in rom mal dringend brauchen
ist eine ehrliche predigt der biblische
untergangs profit gernot hassknecht
klettert auf einen berg und spricht zur
katholischen kirche
[Musik]
warum müssen propheten immer auf berge
lassen
was soll der scheiß so schlechte
nachrichten für alle reformer in der
katholischen kirche vergesst es einfach
manche sachen kann man nicht reformieren
den vatikan nordkorea den öffentlich
rechtlichen rundfunk es geht halt nicht
wie sind wie sie sind
der laden ist und bleibt eine von alten
männern mit spitzen hüten geleitete
machtmaschine mann der jesus gesagt
hätte nee danke
da arbeite ich lieber wieder als
zimmermann auf hiermit eurobasis tut mir
ja auch leid zum beispiel für die
engagierten frauen bei maria 2.0 die
immer noch auf richterinnen hoffen die
memo aus der chefetage
ich hoffe rudolf voderholzer der uns
leider kein interview geben wollte sagt
in einer predigt jesus hat bewusst nur
männer als apostel berufen in der antike
sei das weibliche priestertum durchaus
bekannt gewesen
ihr dienst war oft verbunden mit der
tempel prostitution als darstellung der
fruchtbarkeit der erde
na das hört doch jede frau gerne ganz
gerne bei uns mitmachen als [ __ ] in
jeder normalen firma gibt's nach so
einem spruch abmahnung aber bei denen es
halt nichts normal bis heute trieben
geschiedene wiederverheiratete nur in
einzelfällen das abendmahl
die landen in der hölle nur weil sie
nach 30 jahren eher mal neue achse
neben sich auf dem sofa haben wollen
nochmal zum mitschreiben der laden ist
unreformierten vorschlag meinerseits
macht mal genauso weiter als folklore
verein der sonntag vormittags in
lustigen kostümen das mittelalter
nachspielt warum lütjann markt dafür
aber dann höhe das auch sehr weiß dass
ich als nicht katholik mit meinen
steuergeldern das gehalt form wohl
lieber zahle ich kenne ja auch nix an
scientology
jetzt klettert von dem blöden berg
wieder runter und besucht die gefallenen
frauen im tempel aus ghana und tschüss
nein ich mache hier gar nichts mehr
bevor ihr nicht den kanal abonniert und
ein like dallas ich hab die schnauze
voll
loslassen abo da